ils ont tapé là dessus c'est tout petit
matin vers 6 heures que des policiers
parisiens enfoncent la porte de cette
maison
ils recherchent vincent l'un des fils de
la famille ils sont allés vite ils ont
trouvé la chambre de vincent ils ont dix
cibles en vue
et puis donc après ils m'ont dit on
vient pour complicité de menaces de
destruction de biens et de personnes
voilà et j'étais sur le cul mon père m'a
dit qu'il y avait des voitures de
policiers dans la maison des voisins
mais sinon moi honnêtement j'ai rien vu
et il a juste vu que les personnes avec
des menottes et et la perquisition des
ordinateurs vincent 18 ans est
interpellé dans l' enquête sur les
alertes à la bombe dont plusieurs lycées
parisiens et lyonnais fin janvier le
jeune homme est soupçonné d'avoir rendus
anonymes tous ses appels téléphoniques
c'est un peu choquant il est pour moi il
est sur informatique lui revenait pas
mal je croyais qu un village comme
marsannay pour être épargnés par tout ce
qu'on a connu tout ce que le pays a
connu sur la fin de l'année 2015
et ben quelquefois on peut se croire
tranquille à la campagne et bien il se
passe aussi des choses dans des villages
de et dans la ruralité un village sous
le choc et un père qui ne croit pas du
tout à cette histoire
pour daniel son fils est juste un jeune
passionné d'informatique qui n'a rien
fait de mal je n'y crois pas pas
nuisible et puis faire dire qu'on va
faire sauter alice et vous faire un
attentat c'est une fois du tout son
genre
bon enfin voilà j'en sais pas plus
le jeune homme était connu des services
de police notamment pour une intrusion
dans des systèmes informatiques l'an
dernier
ce soir il a été transféré vers paris où
il va être auditionné